white house correspondent peter ducey
though starts us off tonight
live in the north lawn good evening
peter good evening brett it has now been
a week
since president biden said anything
about the border and since then
the situation has grown his one
appearance today was to promote the
paycheck protection
act and when asked about his thoughts on
what's happening at the border
he didn't have an answer
sir now same question for the press
secretary
look i don't think we need to sit here
and put new labels on what we have
already conveyed is challenging
republicans from border states argue the
crisis is clear
i believe this is deliberate i believe
this is what they want they want open
borders
and that's why they're not acknowledging
that it's a crisis
the numbers are multiplying i'm not
going to confirm numbers from here
but fox has confirmed the number of
migrant children in custody has tripled
in two weeks to 3
the number of migrants seen at the
border more than double the rate this
time last year and the highest of any
january in a decade it happened
78 000 times that month the number of
migrants caught just since march
1st 19 000 and the number of children
detained longer than the legal limit
seventy two hours
thirteen hundred and sixty do you
believe there is a limit into how many
of these unaccompanied minors weaken
place in the united states
well i'm not sure chuck that that's the
question uh the real question is
you know what are they fleeing from uh
two tornadoes
gangs that means site surveys are
underway
we're looking at additional facilities
where we can safely
house children but less than two weeks
ago the white house was just
talking about one extra facility we had
to open
reopen a new facility that had
previously been closed because of covid
protocols
because previously because we can't have
kids in beds next to each other we need
space appropriate
despite the promise to spread children
out because of covid the cdc now says
those facilities can be loaded
to full capacity as the byte
administration refuses
to open schools they have instead
decided to open the border
and to let in thousands of people
potentially who
have got covid you've got children at
the border
that have been separated again from
their parents
we've learned the top republican in the
house kevin mccarthy is going to lead
a delegation of lawmakers down to the
border on monday
president biden sent a similar
delegation down there
this past weekend their job was to go
gather info
and bring it back and brief him and
they've been back for several days
but we are told that briefing still has
not happened yet
brett peter ducey live on the north lawn
peter thank you